hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to my game engine
series so last time we took a look at
the scene hierarchy panel
basically some kind of way of displaying
all of our entities on the screen so
that we can actually like you know
select them
and see what's up and today another
video's to be linked up there by the way
today we're going to continue on with
that and now when we select our entities
our goal is going to be to actually
display information
about what components our entities have
in a separate panel which we're going to
call the properties panel
which is basically very similar to the
inspector inside
unity okay let's just dive in and is my
hair cut off
so unprofessional okay so uh let's hit
f5 we'll see what we had last time so
last time we had
this uh beginnings of a scene hierarchy
panel which we could keep
over here it displays every single
entity that we actually have
actually i really wanted to change fonts
as well but we'll we'll talk about fonts
in a different um
episode because we probably want to
actually add one to the repository
uh but basically we had our clip space
entity
uh our camera entity and this green
square um
and then the camera entity we could also
control by the script and all of that
so my point is we obviously have three
entities here it would be really good
to be able to see what i don't remember
what what is clip space entity
stream can you help me out what is what
does clip space see
clip space did i make that was that
merged or something
what is this clip space and i remember
making why would i name it that it's a
camera all right anyway
back to the profession i'm gonna have to
do some editing on this video i hate
doing that
whatever clip space entity what why is
it
it's a camera that we can switch to
well so the scene hierarchy panel here
displays all of the entities in our
entire scene i think we even added some
uh loose ui support for parenting which
is pretty cool
but now it would be it would be really
good for us to be able to select these
entities and view some more information
about them such as what components they
have
because of course that would be uh
useful because not only could we see
what we've actually added
programmatically
we also want to eventually have the a
have the ui to be able to add new
components to
any entities and also like create new
entities and essentially build up scenes
so what we're going to be doing today is
creating
another panel which is going to be
called our properties panel very similar
to like the unity inspector panel
and this is going to be something that
we will we'll probably end up using this
for more than just the scene hierarchy
panel and its selection context
when we have things like assets that we
might want to change like the import
settings
then it'll probably also show the
properties for basically
anything that is selected and has
properties in our entire
like hazelnut editor here but for now
i want to be able to take the currently
selected entity
and display some information about it
and that's going to be our goal
for today so let's take a look at how we
can do that now i think the first thing
if we're going to see a hierarchy panel
it's pretty easy to get this up and
running
last time when we actually created this
um
uh all of the like this like this scene
hierarchy panel with the uh
you know selection context and all these
i am gui tree node
uh thingies tree nodes trainer like
tree nodes i guess that that makes sense
um we we had the we
we also added this support to actually
select a particular entity
right so if i'm going is item selected
i'll zoom in um then we actually set our
selection context that was important so
that we can actually display
you know which tree node is selected and
that's why you see it highlighted
so since we've already got the selection
context which by the way is of course an
entity we've already got information
about the entity that's currently
selected
so once we select something it's just a
matter of seeing
you know what the entity is which is
just selection context and actually
retrieving its components
and also when we add the ui to be able
to add a component such as like
a camera component or a transform
component transform component probably
already exists but things like mesh
components or script components
then obviously we'll be adding it to the
current selection context
now i also want to be able to deselect
things which we'll talk about in a
minute as well
so to do this let's let's go up here now
we have our scene hierarchy panel i'm
actually going to add this
properties panel right over here inside
our scene hierarchy panel
uh file just because first of all at the
moment it is completely just used for
the scene hierarchy panel
in the future when we do have it across
more of the engine and we'll probably
refactor this out into its own class
but to keep things nice and simple i'll
keep it here we'll call it properties
i'm going and now it's just a matter of
seeing hey
is there anything in the selection
context so if selection context
we could actually draw our components um
so whether or not you want to uh
label this uh as so i guess that's
probably fine
um avoid draw components i'm just going
to bring it out into a function just to
keep things a little bit more simple
no i want to create implementation uh
and then over here we're actually going
to draw
all of the component ui so we've got the
selection context um
now it's probably worth actually passing
in the selection context here
just because uh that way you know if we
for whatever reason wanted to draw
you know something else um then we can
actually easily
just pass in a different entity um
and then what this is going to do is
actually ask the entity hey do you have
certain components and if so let's draw
some ui for it
so let's start with like probably the
tag component realistically is what we
want to start with
but we basically want to go through all
of these um
tag should be the first one because we
also want to have some kind of editable
text box
that will let us rename that stuff so
let's go with the tag component
and then if we go back to editor layer
we were already doing something similar
i think oh actually no sorry we are
doing something similar
inside the scene hierarchy panel because
of course we are drawing
the actual
uh where is it the actual here it is
this right
we're actually you know the name of the
uh tree node inside the scene hierarchy
panel
is of course the name of the entity so
we can retrieve that tag component
if it's got it i mean it's going to have
it but we'll still leave the f check in
here
uh and then we just need to we just need
to actually display it somewhere now
i've already done this in hazel dev so
i'm going to steal some code from there
of course
but basically uh what i did was i just
added a
i am gui input text now i didn't give
this a name
and we'll talk about why later but i
will call a tag for now
uh but in hazeldev i basically did a
little bit more with the ui to make it
look prettier because i don't like for
example
the fact that imgui labels are always on
the right like that's a bit weird i like
to have the label on the left so the way
that you
usually achieve that in iron gui because
it doesn't have support for that is you
basically just
don't you don't display any kind of text
as the actual label
instead what you do is you actually just
do like an im gui text display here you
split up your actual window into like
two columns
and then you can actually draw like the
text or and and then like the label and
then the actual control
on the right side as well which we might
do in the future again not really too
worried about polish
at this point in time we're just trying
to get functionality down so we'll have
the um
we'll have the tag here and then
obviously what this does is
actually takes in a buffer pointer and a
buffer size
so to get this to work um there's a few
different ways you could do that
uh you know i'm just thinking about it
now actually i think that
the best way probably to do this is just
to have some kind of
local buffer the pro one of the one of
the issues with having a local buffer
and by this i just mean literally having
like a buffer like this
is that 256 bytes on the stack this
isn't a recursive function so i don't
think that's going to be too much of a
problem
we could of course just make it static
or even like static to this translation
unit out here
and use it kind of like a scratch buffer
maybe make it a little bit bigger
you can make this bigger of course but
basically what this is going to be
is this is going to be our string that
is our tag
all of the characters there but also we
need to provide it with some more room
than is actually inside this tag because
obviously we could potentially
rename the entity and make the name be
longer than what is currently stored
inside this string
inside the tag component and that would
obviously overflow that buffer so
because of that we need to
we need to have some kind of temporary
buffer here now this by by temporary i
just mean we literally just need it for
this scope
but it's also perfectly reasonable to
have it as a just a global scratch
buffer or something like that that you
can constantly reuse
having it like local to the stack though
might be
nice but again it doesn't really matter
i'm not too fussed with it but now we
can leave it in here
so we're basically going to pass in this
buffer and then the size of course is
going to be well
it's on the stack so we can just write
the size of buffer and that's it
now we've got um and i think that wants
the size in bytes i'm pretty sure
uh and that's it right so now we can
obviously handle it changing
and if it does change we're not actually
passing in the the source string yeah
but we'll get to that
um if it does actually change then guess
what we need to take this tag and just
basically assign it to a new sd string
potentially with this actual buffer and
i think that's fine because there's a
constructor obviously that takes in a
construct pointer
it should be null terminated and i think
everything will be fine so to actually
make it null terminated first of all i'm
going to set
uh everything to zero right so i'm gonna
just mem set it to zero and then i'm
actually going to mem copy
probably do a string copy i don't really
know see the thing is this
may break if like you're dealing with
wide strings or white chars for example
i don't know i don't know if we want to
support wide chars in the future usually
usually i would be all about that but i
think that
like for game engine entities
do we want to support like you know
extended character sets like for
different languages
maybe uh if we do obviously this code
has to be rewritten but for now we'll
ignore that stuff and we'll do
things the simple way so now we'll do a
little bit of a mem copy
to go from uh
to go from well into buffer we're just
going to
um we're just going to grab the c string
of tag
i guess i'll do a string copy uh
and then that's it right uh and then so
now what we should have done is if we
had an entity called camera
then obviously uh you know that's what
the memory looks like for it camera
followed by like is
an actual zero not just not a ascii
character zero
um and then what we're doing here is
allocating enough room for it uh well
enough room for it and as well as what
we could potentially edit it into
and then uh which 256 again if we
technically go over that yes everything
will crash
probably not a great example of this
although i don't think it will happen
but i don't think everything anything
will crash because that's probably why
we're providing i'm going with the size
that's the maximum size we're just not
going to be able to enter any more
characters
than 256 which i think is reasonable for
now at least um
then we're setting every single byte of
this buffer to be zero
and then we're copying this camera uh
probably without was the string copy
copy the zero i don't know if it does
anyway we're copying just basically the
entire string
into this now into this buffer that
we've got here then we're giving that in
to i'm gui and that's what we're editing
when we actually input text into this ui
control
so that's what's going on here and again
if it changes we do that that's pretty
much it you know what let's just
let's grab that for now and let's just
give it a run so
if there's a selection context we should
be able to draw the name and we should
be able to change the name of our
entities now which is pretty cool i mean
that didn't take too long but
we've done something nice and powerful
and i guess which
we we probably like the compiler there
was actually telling us that
uh they were doing something wrong well
it was warning us
about where's my output it was warning
us uh because we if we look at the build
because string cup uh string copy
function may be unsafe and that we
should use string copy underscore s
or crt secure no warnings so i guess we
will use underscore s
the only real difference between uh
underscore s is that this actually takes
in
some kind of size um and the size is
actually a
uh a compile time thing that's a bit
weird i didn't know what was that no
size in bytes and then
source and then size and by supposedly
the destination size so this would be
256 right
or size of buffer that was weird so i
guess there was a templated version but
anyway
so that that basically lets us um that
basically protects against overflows
because obviously now there's actually
validation
for how big destination is um obviously
we know how big source is because it's
going to be up until the null
termination character
but destination no clue if that will fit
or not but now we do because we're
actually validating that
all right let's take let's take another
look
um and we should be able to see our
properties panel
which is over here all right let's grab
that and dock it into here
now it should stay here as long as that
i'm going to ini file gets written too
and now if we click on these various
things you can see that we see our tag
and again i
really don't like the level being on the
right but we'll change that eventually
and now we should be able to take this
clip space and it's here no idea why
it's called that i believe that's our
second camera camera b
let's rename it to camera b so if i get
rid of that and type in camera b
obviously as i type like the a key and
stuff it actually moves the camera
but you can see that now we've renamed
it to camera b which is pretty cool so
up here it shows up as camera b
and we also see it here awesome now
let's continue on with this stuff let's
go into the transform component now the
transform component is a little bit
tricky
um because there's a lot of different
controls that we likely want for this
translation rotation scale stuff like
that
let's just deal with the translation for
today and then we might actually
dedicate an episode to
transform components because they are
they can be very very confusing
um so to do this what i want to do is uh
basically just have a little bit of a
like a float three
uh like a drag float three or something
um
that goes over drag flow three that just
goes over
um we'll call this uh translation or
position i guess
that goes over the
last column of the matrix so get
component transform component
dot transform
and then if we actually just do glm
value pointer
transform
and it's just gonna want is it's not
gonna be fine i guess should be right
um yeah it's gonna be fine because it is
a vec 4 technology but again we're just
doing value pointer and we probably need
to include that
include glm gtc type pointer
um and then oops and then we'll do
so we'll do a drag float and then we'll
do
speed of one yeah
we'll do maybe speed at 0.5 um
min and max we won't touch obviously and
then that's it
all right so now we can basically and we
can check to see if that's been modified
i don't know if i've talked about this
this but i'm going with pretty much any
widget that i'm gui has
it returns a boolean right so that
bullet is whether or not it's been used
whether or not it's been modified
so that's obviously very useful because
instead of constantly
like well actually we don't need it for
this but uh in the case of like rotation
you know rotation inside a matrix you
probably want to decompose the matrix
get the rotation possibly as a
quaternion maybe
give it to like euler angles or
something like that um
and then modify that and then
reconstruct the matrix instead of doing
that
every single like frame essentially
every single ui rendering
uh instead of doing that you can
actually detect whether or not
that rotation or translation or the
matrix has been changed or not
and then if it has then you can update
it and like you know recalculate it
um which which is obviously a lot better
for performance so in general
just keep an eye out for things like
this you don't want to be doing stuff
if you don't need to just do a little if
check and then then that way you can
respond
to your ui controls actually being
tinkered with
so um in this case though we actually
don't need to do anything because it's
just going to modify the matrix in place
since we it's just
it's just the translation we don't need
to actually uh
rebuild the matrix or anything like that
okay so now if we hit f5
um we should hopefully see uh the
transform
okay so there's our camera entity clip
space empty obviously it didn't save the
name
um but you can see it's got a position
here
uh oh we need headings for all these
components don't we we'll do that in a
minute um
so we have all of these things and then
we can obviously uh shift this around
0.5 might even be too much here um maybe
i'll make it 0.25 it's kind of
difficult to set a value like that
obviously i don't know what like unity
does
um maybe i should investigate but maybe
it's
up to your zoom level as well i'm not
sure but obviously it's hard because you
don't know how big the scene is going to
be
um although i guess moving by like what
is what's that going to be like 25
centimeters or something
every um you know every uh yeah
might be harsh you know maybe something
like point one would be a little bit
more reasonable
for dragging these things around but
anyway the point is we can now
obviously um move around uh you know we
can grab like this green square for
example
and then shift it around we can grab the
camera and then we can like shift the
camera around
and we can we can control that now using
our properties panel which is pretty
cool
now i want to um uh i want to have some
kind of heading for this right so we
should have an actual
like it's actually some kind i think
what the what i did in hazel dev was i
basically had like a little bit of a
tree node
uh header for it right the same way the
same thing that we saw inside the scene
hierarchy
panel and all of those uh various
entities there
um just so that we can essentially
collapse components that we don't care
about
and organize things a little bit better
so the way that i did that was basically
i had um if it's got a transform
component we don't need to display it if
we don't have it
but if it's got it then i basically just
made a tree node
here which uh needs to take some kind of
unique identifier for this now what i
use
here i basically use entity
um
this doesn't really matter too much what
this is as long as it's unique
i think what i did in hazel dev was i
just basically got the type id
of transom component because obviously
that's going to be unique across all of
these components
so if you just use siebels as type id
with transform
with transform component and then you
get the hash code for it
that will that should give you a unique
uh integer that will basically represent
that particular type
um and that way you won't get conflicts
with any other ones i don't know if that
will actually conflict with this trainer
no i mean it shouldn't because it's in a
completely different um it's in a
completely different window
however we will talk a little bit more
about i'm goi's like identifies and
stuff in the future because we'll be
like pushing and popping ids and
handling ui a little bit differently
than we are now because obviously right
now we're just doing i'm gooey stuff
and crazy stuff like this but in the
future we want to be a little bit more
um i guess abstract with how we how we
actually handle our ui as we begin to
develop our
actual style for our editor ui and that
way we want to obviously
reuse our kind of style library instead
of continually just using imgui's raw
stuff
um anyway so we'll have the hash code uh
we'll do
um i also did default open right so i am
going tree note flags
default open because we want all of our
components to be open by default we
don't want to have to go through each of
them and open them
that's a bit weird um and then uh
we'll call this the transform component
obviously
all right so if it is in fact open which
should be by default then we'll display
all of this stuff if it's not then it's
not and then obviously at the end of
this we need to do a tree pop
there we go so now if we take a look at
the difference between
uh what we had and what we just added
then as you should be able to see um we
now have a header for this called
transform that we can collapse
and it should be expanded by default and
again we'll we'll deal with like padding
and stuff like that later but we're just
getting the base kind of layout down
we also want to have some kind of like
plus button potentially or some kind of
extra button here
that we can click to remove um like this
component
uh maybe even like to copy the component
so that we can paste it to a different
entity stuff like that
but we'll leave that as is for now what
other components do we have that are
useful
um i think we've got i just look at
components
oh i wanted to do this deselecting as
well now script component at this point
no point displaying that
um camera spy render transform
uh i guess the camera component is
something we could
talk about but this this is like one of
those things that's going to take like
half an hour to implement properly so
i'm tempted to just leave that for a
different episode because it's more of
an overview but
what i want to do is talk about this
deselecting as well so
at the moment we actually have no way to
deselect nfc so once we've selected this
and the properties panel has this that's
kind of it
right the properties panel is always
going to display this because we are
always
we will we always have this empty as our
selection context and we've got no
way to clear it however um we can
obviously
make it so that when we click on a blank
space inside the scene hierarchy or in
the scene even
we're not doing picking through the
scene yet but when we do
then that will just deselect everything
so to make the blank
space inside the scene hierarchy panel
work we basically want to go
into um where we render it and then
after we've
done all of our entity node stuff we can
actually just check to see
if uh well it'd be great to use
something called is item clicked however
that doesn't work with windows that
works with actual items
inside windows so for this we can just
do if the window is hovered
right and uh the mouse button is pressed
so
if mouse is mouse pressed
is mouse down here's mouse down
uh button zero i guess which is left
mouse button i don't know if there's
actually an enum for it
um i guess we might be able to check
left is that a thing zero equals left
well they've just got a documentation
here that says to use zero so i assume
zero is fine
so if we press the left mouse button
and this window is in fact hovered um
uh then uh we're going to set selection
context
to nothing right we're going to clear it
like that
now it's worth noting that this mouse
down is window hovered
situation this actually has
this thing called i'm gooey hovered
flags which we can set
and you can see that by default um
allow when blocked by popup so return
true even if a pop-up window is normally
blocking it or if
um uh i think that's
if blocked by active item so basically
by default what that's saying because
you need a special flag to allow it even
when it's blocked by an active item
items will actually
block this so if an item in like if an
item before we get to this point in the
window has already handled our click
then it's not gonna it's not gonna
respond here so what that means is that
um when we actually draw the entity
nodes here
like which is the rest of everything
else when we do our selection here
that's going to happen first and thus
it's not going to filter
all the way down to here so this will
truly be if you click on a blank
space not if you click on something and
then the other
other entity as well so you can see i
can still select them as normal
but if i click here that's it they're
gone and in fact i can even click in
between
and they'll go away as well which is
pretty cool so now i can deselect
entities
which is pretty amazing okay
that's going to wrap up this video hope
you guys enjoyed uh
i'm all over the place with this hope
you guys enjoyed this is this episode of
the game
engine series don't forget to hit the
like button if you did you can also help
support the series by going to
patreon.com
where you will find all of the hazel dev
code which i've mostly been stealing
code from
throughout this entire episode as well
as just a much more advanced version
of hazel with like a full-on like level
editor and like 3d graphics and vulcan
support now
and c-sharp scripting and just it's it's
amazing you need to check it out
and also help support everything uh that
you're seeing in front of you
anyway hope you guys enjoyed as always
stream is over here to say goodbye as
well bye youtube
workstream and next time we're gonna
probably continue on with this stuff
again i don't want to focus too much on
ui for components just yet
i want to get everything kind of up and
running and then we'll start actually
refining it and going over it
making our editor and hazelnut look
pretty with like different
fonts and stuff like that and just
generally polishing it into
what should be hopefully an amazing
engine anyway i'll see you guys later
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you